tonight Biden's border crisis it is
causing chaos across the entire country
including in the heart of New York
City's Times Square where a mob of
illegal immigrants were caught in a very
disturbing video look at this uh
Saturday night beating up New York City
police officers you can see it right
there four suspects they were arrested
they were charged uh with assault but
according to sources they were
reportedly released back in onto the
streets without bail of course New York
City he's had New York State's no Bale
laws uh you know think about this for a
second no Bale for a mob of people
beating up cops also tonight the New
York Post is reporting that illegal
immigrants are now forming pickpocketing
crews in the Big Apple causing new
headaches for an already strained mypd
they have more people leaving than
they've ever had in history as we have
been reporting on the show the illegal
immigrant crisis it is no longer
impacting just States along the border
every state is now a border state it has
now reached every corner of our country
it is wreaking havoc on our biggest
cities and even small towns and sadly
all of it was preventable this is all a
direct result of Joe Biden's failures
his dereliction of Duty his
unwillingness to enforce the law and
upholds his oath to our Constitution and
by the way this is the administration
that inherited what was the most secure
Border in US history but Joe's work to
undo every sing Le Trump error policy
that worked and on day one by the way it
was Biden he signed the executive orders
that revoke Trump's efforts to exclude
illegal immigrants from the sentence he
strengthened DACA he canceled Trump's
interior enforcement rule he halted
border wall construction he ended the
remain in Mexico policy and he let title
42 expire among other things it's time
for Joe now to Simply he did all that
with the stroke of a pen well one more
stroke of the pen he can reinstate the
Trump policies that secured our border
in the first place uh this is now a
clear matter of National Security stop
saying you Congress needs to do this
you're the one that undid it you're the
one that can fix it yourself but he
doesn't want to do it thousands of ilal
immigrants pouring in from some of our
biggest adversaries thousands from
Afghanistan and Egypt hundreds from Iran
and Syria tens of thousands from Russia
and China and there here are the
questions that no one seems to be asking
why are they uh coming from those long
distances to get to our Southern border
why are we allowing them to do so and as
I've been warning I would say with
almost 100% certainty and again I pray
I'm I'm wrong I pray to God I'm wrong
the terrorists are taking advantage of
Joe's open borders and there are Terror
cells likely in this country plotting
planning scheming and attack against our
homeland and the blame for that will lie
squarely on the shoulders of Joe Biden
but things are only getting worse once
once again according to brand new CBP
data well the record for illegal
immigrants entering our country that was
shattered in the month of December for
the LA one month ago with an astounding
371,000 incounters but that did not stop
Biden from telling reporters yesterday
yeah I I I did all I can to secure the
Border you did all you could to open the
Border that's as big a lie as as him
telling us for 3 years the borders
closed the Border is secure the border
is closed the border is secure here's a
quick
reminder sounds to most folks like a
crisis well look it's way down now we've
now gotten control precisely that the
border is closed nor could I have been
clear and continue to be so which is the
border is closed the United States will
continue to enforce our laws and secure
our border the Border um we are working
to make the Border more secure you're
confident this border is
secure we
have a secure Border in that that is a
priority for Any Nation including ours
in our Administration we agree that uh
the border is
secure they're all just flat out lying
to all of us Biden now changing his tune
and saying oh uh Congress needs to pass
a bill then I'll secure the Border uh
Joe says he will let in what a few
thousand ille immigrants every single
day that's not a closed border that's
insane there should be zero Joe doesn't
need Congress to do his job Joe can
reinstate the policies that worked under
the last Administration with a stroke of
a pen just like he rescinded them with a
stroke of a pen here's Donald Trump from
earlier today take a look you have the
right to close up your border you don't
need bills that complicate it and make
it to a level that nobody's going to be
able to do it and the minimum was 5,000
people a day if that can be right I it's
hard to believe that that can be right
but they were
negotiating to allow 5,000 people a day
that's a tremendous amount nobody wants
to have that happen to our country and
they're still not going to know where
they're coming
from right now we have no idea who these
people are that are pouring into our
countries is anyone really surprised
things have gotten this far out of
control remember in 2020 it was Biden
repeatedly promising to ha deportations
in his first 100 days and only Deport
illegal immigrants who have committed a
felony on our soil you might remember
this take a look should someone who is
here without documents and that is his
only offense should that person be
deported that person should not be the
focus of deportation we should
fundamentally change the way we deal
with things what exact changes would you
bring to ice as an agency I would hold
ice agents accountable if in fact they
stepped over my executive order you only
arrest for the purpose of dealing with a
felony that's committed and I don't
count drunken driving as a felony I will
send to the desk immediately a bill that
requires the access to citizenship for
11 million undocumented folks number one
number two in the first 100 days of my
Administration no one no one will be
deported at all from that point on the
only deportations that will take place
are commissions of felonies in the
United States America so to be clear
only felons get deported and everyone
else has to say yes nobody and some of
you going to get mad at me with this but
nobody is going to be deported in my
first 100 days until we get through the
point that we find out the only
rationale for deportation will be
whether or not whether or not you've
committed a felony while in the
country side note do you notice the
significant cognitive decline now do you
see how how dramatic it's been let me be
clear as it relates to the border the
situation there is the direct result of
Biden's dereliction of Duty it is a
major national security crisis it is a
clear and present danger hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else